Thanks for coming to my talk.
Really excited to kind of peel
back the curtains a little bit
on Quarto and show it off
to the world for some
of the first times.
My name is Tom Mock,
and if you want
to follow along
with these slides,
you can do so at
rstd.io/quarto-curious.
So really for the
longest time and why
I'm so excited about
talking about it now
is that for the longest time we
weren't talking about Quarto.
We were kind of working
on it behind the scenes,
getting things ready for
that first stable release.
In April of this year,
we actually did our first
kind of beta release
or some of the
initial soft release.
Alison Hill wrote up this
great talk or great blog
post called We Don't Talk
About Quarto Until Now.
Alison was one of
the folks who used
to work with the
development team
before she moved
over to Voltron Data.
And it just really kind of
opened the floodgates to people
hearing about Quarto, started
talking a little bit on Twitter
or generally just
generating some hubbub.
For the most part, people
were really excited,
you know, they're just like,
"Oh, I hear about Quarto.
"Let me try it out.
I really like it."
So Kelly said, you know,
she stayed up all night
switching over our marketing
materials over to Quarto.
And her kind of takeaway was
"It's pretty rad, my dudes,
I like it."
So she's enjoying it.
And there was even
some excitement
in the Python community.
So if you're familiar with
Jeremy Howard or the nbdev
team or Fast.ai,
they're actually
moving some of their
work over into Quarto
and using that along
with Jupyter Notebooks.
In fact, Hamel is
going to be talking
about that tomorrow
in his talk, talking
about the next generation
version of nbdev.
Now, while there's
a lot of excitement
in both the R and
the Python community,
there was also people who
had a few more questions.
And I think that's where
a lot of y'all are.
Y'all are the Quarto curious
and you've come to my talk
to hear a little bit about, what
is Quarto? Why should I care?
What's different
about it? What's
going on with RMarkdown
and all of that?
First off, don't worry,
RMarkdown is not going away.
We're still going
to maintain it.
If bug fixes happen,
we'll definitely fix them.
Ultimately, the question
that people have is
When can I switch to Quarto?
When is it ready?
Is it stable?
What's going on with it?
So ultimately, we'll
answer that question
by saying, what is Quarto?
So Quarto is the next
generation version
of RMarkdown for everyone.
And that everyone kind of
has an asterisk to it in
terms of not 6 billion people
or whatever's
around in the world,
but for really any
data science language
or any future language.
As JJ talked about in
his keynote this morning,
we want to build a
100-year company.
And while that today
might mean working
in R and Python and
Julia and JavaScript
and other languages,
in the future,
we want kind of a
language-agnostic tool
that can work with anything,
anything that becomes
popular in the future.
To make it a bit more clinical
instead of just saying
the next generation of R
Markdown, Quarto, if we define
it, is an open-source, scientific
and technical publishing system
built on Pandoc.
So Pandoc is a
command line tool
that's also used by RMarkdown.
So again, there's going
to be a lot of familiarity
as we go through these
slides, and we'll
build up a mental
model of how Quarto
is a little bit different
than RMarkdown and some
of the improvements.
Quarto itself is a
command line interface,
or what is called a CLI.
So you can access Quarto via your
terminal, whether you are in RStudio
or any text editor or any
terminal on your computer.
And this example, I'm just
calling quarto --help to see
what can I do with Quarto
once I've installed it
on my machine. It'll print
out something like this
and I've abbreviated
it so we can
see the slides nice and big.
But the commands here
that we're looking at
are I can use quarto
render, to render documents
from the plaintext format
out to say HTML or PDF
or to a website.
I can use quarto preview
what you'll actually
render the document and then
maintain a background web
server.
So as I make changes, it
shows those in real time
on the actual rendered output.
And because it's a
publishing system,
I cannot only render it locally,
but I can publish it to the web
places like GitHub pages or Netlify
or something else we'll talk
about in the future
called Quarto Pubs.
To really kind of build up
our mental model, though,
and help differentiate a
little bit between RMarkdown
and Quarto,
we need to kind of talk
about what RMarkdown is
and what is happening
behind the scenes.
When you use RMarkdown
in your daily work,
you're probably just
thinking, Oh yeah,
I open up an R
Markdown inside RStudio
type some code, type some
text, and then I render it
and I get something beautiful
out. Behind the scenes,
or things that are
happening here in the middle,
is actually a
little bit of magic.
It's not real magic,
it's code, but it's
things that are happening
as intermediary steps.
So when your render
your R Markdown,
the R code is evaluated by
a package called knitr
that will evaluate R code,
generate graphics, generate
tables, embed HTML widgets
and all the other magic
that you're building.
This generates an intermediary
Markdown file or a .md file
that is then passed
to pandoc, which
actually converts a
plaintext .md into something
like a report.
So a word document, a
PDF report, or a HTML page
or a presentation just
like the presentation
I'm giving today,
something in HTML,
or a more complex project
like a website or a book.
So this process
is great and it's
been around for almost 10
years. You know, knitr is an old package.
It's robust.
We've been using it a long time.
Something to note,
though, is that it
has this hard dependency on
R. So to use RMarkdown,
whether you're using R
or other languages, you
have to have to have R,
you have to knitr, you have to have Markdown.
And some of the formatting
or preprocessing that occurs
to the document actually occurs
with literal R code written
in the RMarkdown
package. For Quarto,
we have a similar diagram.
And for some of you, if
you're not looking closely,
this might look like
the exact same workflow,
but there's a few
differences we'll note.
Number one, rather
than using a .Rmd,
I'm now using a .qmd or a
Quarto Markdown document.
It's going to feel almost
identical to R Markdown,
which is great, and we're
still using knitr.
So knitr will evaluate
our code from our .qmd,
generate an intermediary
Markdown file,
but now we have another
word added to pandoc.
We have pandoc
with Lua filters.
So we've moved any preprocessing
or post-processing into Quarto,
that command line interface,
or to affect them with pandoc
rather than having to call them
from R. What this does is still
allows us to create the
same reports, presentations
and projects that
are available, but we
don't have to have R in
the system to use this.
You could use Quarto
on a fresh computer
and not have R
anywhere in it and just
render Markdown as opposed to
code. So people could use it
for scientific communication
without actually
having to execute code.
But because, again, we're
trying to become this company
that is building for
all of data science
and building for scientific
communication in general,
we want to do more than
just evaluate for R code.
So Quarto also extends to
other languages.
So Quarto can now use
Jupyter and Jupyter Kernels
as the engine rather
than just R And knitr.
So you can imagine Jupyter
Kernels include things
like Julia or Python.
We also have JavaScript
you can execute via Quarto.
So you have this availability
of not just being limited to R
but collaborating with
other people in Python
or if you're a Python dev
yourself, also using Python
within your Quarto documents.
And again, the output
that you're creating
is not any different.
You're just using
a different engine
because you're using a
different programming language.
And if I'm using
Python, all I have
to have is Python on my system.
If I'm using Julia, all I have
to have is Julia on my system.
And I can switch between
them if I wanted to
without having to change
the overall document.
For some other people who
are working with, say, Julia
or Python or familiar
with Jupyter,
they don't want to use
a plaintext format.
They might not even use RStudio.
They want to use Jupyter
Notebooks or Jupyter
Lab as their environment,
and that's possible too.
So you can use a
literal .ipython notebook,
or what's called
a Jupyter Notebook,
and whether you're
using Julia or Python,
you can execute
code inside of that
and with essentially the
same rendering process,
create the exact same output.
So they're using this plaintext
.qmd or a more complex kind
of binary format like
Jupyter, all of those
can create the
same presentations,
the same reports,
and the same projects
that you want to create.
If we think of what .qmd looks
like a little bit to what
your working mental model of,
say an R Markdown document,
we have the YAML header,
or the metadata that
says do this with my document.
So format: html, create
an HTML static page.
Here we have side by
side choice of choosing
an engine for knitr in R or say
choosing an engine of Jupyter
or a Python 3 or Julia
to execute that code.
And again, you're
executing it natively.
You're not wrapping it in R
code or wrapping it in Python code
to execute the opposites.
You're just evaluating it
in its normal engine.
You can then write some code.
So we have here a group_by()
summarize() with mtcars and dplyr
and then in a Python library
called siuba, both of which
look relatively similar,
but one's evaluating purely
in R and one purely in Python.
Then we have a bunch
of text or Markdown
that we're using to, you know, create
the actual prose or the text
inside the document.
And you can see that
this spans both columns.
There's no difference in
the Markdown you're writing
or the way that you
use Quarto to kind
of typeset your document.
That is the same between
any language you're using.
So again, whether you're
using R or Python or Jupyter
or whatever else, you can
write these documents.
And again get the
exact same output,
whether you're changing
your engine or not.
Cool! So we got a
plain text format.
It looks kind of
similar to RMarkdown.
I'm still not sold.
What's the difference?
So let's talk about that.
Number one, Quarto is
one install, what
we call "batteries included".
So when you actually install
the latest version of RStudio
that was released on Monday,
Quarto is just there.
It's installed with RStudio.
So as soon as you download
the newest version of RStudio
or upgrade it in the future,
you have access to Quarto.
You don't have to
install anything else.
You can just start using it.
You would need an engine,
if you wanted to use R,
then you install R. If you wanted
to use Julia, you install Julia
or python, you install Python.
But for at least RStudio users,
it's baked in to using it.
So great!
It's always around and you never
really have to think about it
or have to update your packages.
It's just there.
The other half of that
"batteries included" though,
is that there's a
whole bunch of formats
that have been
created over the past
5 or 10 years of RMarkdown.
So you have your basic formats
like HTML documents or Word
documents, PDF,
different presentations
like this that are made in
reveal.js or even an advanced layout
like distill.
That's several different
R Markdown packages. In Quarto,
it's just all there.
That one install of
Quarto brings along
all the different
formats and also includes
the even more complex formats.
So things like websites
or blogs or books
or interactive
documents, all of that
can also be done just with
the one install of Quarto.
So rather than having to manage
a bunch of different R Markdown
ecosystems that were
developed at different times,
it might have different syntax,
you have batteries included one
install with a shared syntax.
There's still a
few things we want
to add into Quarto to match
full parity with R Markdown.
Specifically, flexdashboard is one
of the ones that we're
really passionate
about adding quickly.
And that's a way of creating
dashboards with Quarto
as well as the older
version of flexdashboard in R Markdown.
Great! So, it's a little
bit easier to install.
It might even be installed
automatically for you.
The other part is
that you want to stay
in the comfort of
your own workspace.
If I asked you to
bake a cake and I
told you to go do it in
the corporate kitchen here,
it might be really hard
versus going to your own home
and baking it at your own
kitchen table, probably
a bit easier.
Similarly with Quarto,
you get to choose and stay
within the comfort of
your own workspace.
So you can obviously
use it inside RStudio.
It's pre-installed there.
It's going to again feel
almost identical to RMarkdown.
So all of that work you've
done to learn RMarkdown,
or if you're learning RMarkdown or Quarto
for the first time,
learning Quarto can be applied
within the RMarkdown or sorry,
within the RStudio ecosystem.
You still have the button for render.
You don't have to
go and use the CLI,
but it's still there for
you, and it's actually
embedded into different
functions that
are available through RStudio.
But again, when
you say, "Oh, I want
to collaborate with my
colleague or my friend,"
and they're saying,
"Oh, I work in Julia
"and I don't really
like using RStudio.
"Like that's not the editor I
want to use," or "I'm a Python dev
and I really want to work
in a Jupyter Notebook."
Quarto works just as well
in a Jupyter notebook,
so you can use that as
your editor if you want to.
Again, we've got kind of on
the left this idea of that's
the IPython notebook
you're working in.
You're writing pure, normal
Jupyter Notebook code.
The only thing that's
different is that at the top
you now have a raw
chunk with the YAML
that's defining
what's the format?
What do you want to effect?
And then on the right you
have a Quarto preview.
So when you're
typing and saving,
it'll actually
re-render and show you
the output instantly
as it builds it out.
And again, maybe you
don't like using Jupyter.
Maybe that's not what
you're wanting to look at.
Maybe you use VS
Code as your editor
and you're really
passionate about that
because you also work in, say,
JavaScript or other languages.
We actually developed a
Quarto extension for VS Code.
So you get this rich
interactive experience
both in a notebook format--
So, using again a plain .qmd
as opposed
to a Jupyter Notebook-- and
you can also do quarto preview
and get that real
time output as well.
So whatever editor
you want or whatever
editor you have to collaborate
with your colleagues on,
they can stay in the comfort
of their own workspace.
You can stay in your own
comfortable workspace,
and you can still collaborate
across a document with a shared
syntax.
The other part of what
building for
RStudio and building
for other editors
like VS Code is
we have things like rich
autocompletion, which wasn't always
available and is something
that's added in Quarto.
So, I'm editing a document
I might remember,
Oh yeah, I'm using format HTML,
but what else can I do here?
And if I click Control Space
inside RStudio or VS Code,
it'll actually pull up all
the options that are possible.
Almost like with R
code inside the editor,
you can hover over
it and see what
does this function actually
do. That works in YAML
and it also works
in chunk options.
Again, there's dozens of
chunk options you can do,
and while some of
them are very niche,
you're not going to
use them all the time.
Those are very powerful for
knowing exactly what you
need to do and seeing like,
oh, I need to change figures.
I just start typing figures
and it will autocomplete
to what's available.
And again, whether
you're working
in Python or R or
RStudio or VS Code,
this is available for you.
Great, so we've got some
autocompletion in Python
and R, maybe we want to
talk more about formats
and we want to get
excited about that.
So this is actually
an HTML widget.
You'll notice that
I'm pulling it over.
This is actually
where we are today.
So we're at the National Harbor.
I can click on this and it
says "We are here, together!"
So I can drag that
over a little bit.
It'll load. The internet's
a bit bad in here,
so it's not loaded all the way.
But importantly, you
can see I'm actually
interacting with it with R code.
So you can do Shiny,
you can do HTML widgets
or other things you've built
and put those into Quarto.
And in Python or your
Python colleagues,
they can also embed what
are called Jupyter Widgets.
So similarly, you
have the ability
to create interactivity
on the client side,
both with Python and with R
within a single Quarto document
or in separate Quarto documents.
Another part of
interactivity that Quarto adds,
though, is beyond just
using R and Python.
It even embeds a
version of JavaScript
called Observable JavaScript.
This is an extension
to vanilla JavaScript
created by Mike Bostock,
who's also the author of D3,
that might be one you're more
familiar with in the JavaScript
land.
And now we have a reactive
JavaScript library
that might look to you like
a little bit like Shiny.
I have the ability to create
and interact with different tags
and it will actually
change the graphic.
Or I could do things
like filter the data
to have specific bill lengths
for this penguin's data set.
And again, this is
baked into Quarto,
so you don't have to
install another thing.
This interactivity is added
for the document itself.
So we've got this kind of
idea of the interactivity,
different editors.
We can also kind of unify a lot
of the syntax that was created
across years of RMarkdown.
So again, this is
next-gen RMarkdown,
RMarkdown itself is not
being uninstalled from the web
and removed from the internet.
We're still maintaining it.
We'll fix any bugs, but our
new dev kind of effort
is going to go towards
quarto and to knitr.
So knitr will still power
RMarkdown, still power Quarto,
but we're focusing on Quarto
as this next generation
of data science and technical
science communication.
You might be asking
yourself, OK, well, I've
got a lot of old RMarkdowns
that I want to use.
So for some of you,
keep using them.
We're still going to
maintain RMarkdown.
You don't have to switch
if you don't want to.
You can keep using it.
But Quarto can actually
render R Markdown documents
so you can take your existing
RMarkdown documents
and render them over to whatever
format you want via Quarto.
So whether you're
staying in RMarkdown
or switching them over, you
can still render them out.
And in fact, this unification
of different formats,
let's say we were
trying to render
to HTML and to PDF. For
HTML, we use things like CSS
and raw HTML. For PDF,
we're going to be using LaTeX
and other things like that.
Normally you'd have to write
a lot of manual code in there
to convert between them.
But for this document, I'm not
writing any CSS or any LaTeX.
I'm only using Quarto and I
can create a nicely typeset
document like this.
It's got a picture
in the sidebar,
it's got a table of contents
and all sorts of other footnotes
and things.
That document in PDF
looks almost identical.
You're obviously constrained
to what PDF can do.
So you don't have
Hover Text and you
don't have the same
type of interactivity
as HTML, but without having
to write anything else
besides Quarto code
or Quarto Markdown,
I'm able to generate these two
very well typeset documents
from a single source.
So single source
publishing for this.
And again, Quarto is extended
for other languages.
So this typesetting and all
the different things it brings
are made with Lua filters
rather than an R package.
So things that people
write in Python language
and in R or in Julia are
cross-language and cross-format
compatible.
So we're meeting these users
in their native language.
So when you are
collaborating, you're not
fighting with each
other, but you're
merging around a common syntax.
Those people might ask, well,
what to do about my existing
IPython notebooks?
I don't want to get rid of them.
The answer is
essentially the same.
I can quarto render any IPython notebook
and send it over to the format.
The only difference is an
IPython notebook might actually
store computation inside of it.
So you can either tell Quarto,
"Hey, take this document
and render it top to bottom," or
"Using the embedded execution,
"just format it out
to something else
or change the format
to the final output."
And in fact, Quarto
has a helper tool
to allow you to convert between
a plaintext .qmd and an
IPython notebook itself.
So you can swap back and forth
whether you're using IPython notebooks
or Quarto without having
to change the source code,
you can actually convert
back and forth between them.
You can also extend
Quarto so we have
things like short codes.
So if you wanted to add
something in to the open source
Quarto, you could
use a short code like this
that will insert things
like Font Awesome icons,
or you can add filters
that will actually
change the overall
appearance of a document.
And again, this is not
limited to any language.
So any extensions that you
write in a Python world
work in R and anything
in R works in Python,
you can also add
entirely new formats.
So maybe you want to create
a format for your company.
You can create your own cool
company format for reveal.js.
So these extensions
allow you to go further
with Quarto as we move
forward and add more things.
And then lastly, I mentioned
this idea of Quarto Pubs,
so Quarto can actually
publish the thing you just
rendered to the
Internet, so you can
publish to GitHub or to
Netlify or RStudio Connect.
But we're now announcing
that Quarto Pubs exist.
It's a free resource.
It allows you to publish
anything you create locally
and put that out on
the web at a URL
you choose and manage
all of your documents
that you're publishing out.
So this is very exciting.
I would recommend
signing up quickly
to go grab your preferred
username and you can use that.
The last part I'll
say is, again, you
can use Quarto in RStudio Connect
and RStudio Workbench already.
So if you do have those
products available for you,
we have some examples
of using them
and you're welcome
to go check them out.
And with that, we're getting
close to the end of the talk.
So I want to give a shout out
to the entire Quarto dev team.
Quarto's crafted
with love and care
by the same team that works
on Quarto and RMarkdown,
and you can contribute
yourself if you
want to contribute,
whether an extension
or to the Quarto CLI itself.
I've got a summary of the
talks that are available
and other things coming
up and some takeaways
with the batteries included,
the shared syntax, the ability
to choose your editor
and your language,
and the fact that RMarkdown
is not going anywhere.
We're still maintaining
it, but we're
going to be building in a lot
of our new features into Quarto.
With that, thank
you for your time.
I'm happy to take questions
after the fact down
on the lounge or you can
reach out to me on Twitter.
Thank you, and have a
great and safe conference.